so I asked the question yesterday why is
Herz dropping all these Teslas okay and
Tom gave the most logical reasonable
answer I'm like okay that makes sense to
me on why they would do that Herz is
selling no I'm sorry Tom didn't give
that Rob gave that yesterday when we
were um good job Rob podcast prep Herz
is selling 20,000 EVS so it can buy more
gas guzzlers The Verge look at the title
of it the title is doing what it's
trashing Herz meaning no matter what
Herz does they're not winning yes
they're selling 20,000 EV so it can buy
more gas guzzlers but is Herz making the
right decision if you read the full
story and logic behind it it sounds like
they are so 20,000 cars approximately
onethird of its Global EV Fleet is what
they're selling and use the proceeds to
purchase gas powerered vehicles after
facing unexpected uh depreciation and
damage cost amounting to $245 million
for its EVS the decision aims to better
balance Supply against expected demand
of EVS as the company couldn't find
enough customers for its EES despite
previously setting a 25% EV Fleet Target
for 2024 again I love this one they say
by 2035 there will be no gas guzzling
cars in the state of California and then
Common Sense hits results hits and you
realize it's not an effective method
Nome but it's a good campaign message
for you to give Hurtz shift from scaling
up to EV ambition to selling off EV
reflects the challenges faced by the
company and the broader industry as
softening demand and EV ownership
challenges such as charging and upkeep
impact plans for Ev adoption while EV
sales continue to grow the rate of
growth has slowed prompting companies to
reassess their EV investment rob you
have a uh uh Tesla yourself right and
you're a Tesla owner so what what what
logic do you see with the store here
yourself well first of all whenever
there's for my experience anytime
there's an issue with your Tesla the
only person that can fix it if there's
any type of mechanical issue is a Tesla
representative or Elon Musk yes um like
when I needed to get my tires rotated I
didn't take it to a shop they came to me
they sent a Tesla technician to my house
and switched out the the tires from the
front to the back um and then the other
thing is charging with these vehicles
it's if you're not if you don't have
hands-on experience with the vehicles
it's very hard to understand how the
charging Works um when you go faster you
eat more of the battery away so you have
to pre-plan some of that stuff you'll
get in the car and you'll put in your
destination it'll tell you how much
battery you have how many miles to get
there but if you go 75 or above it
dwindles and it so a lot of people will
run out of power not knowing that
they're not going to get to a charger in
time and it's not like there's charging
stations every couple of blocks you're
talking about 40 50 60 miles in between
charging stations so if you run low on
battery the only way that you can get to
a charging station if the battery runs
out is they send a tow truck out to get
you they put your car on the tow truck
and then they drive that to the charging
station that runs on gas let me ask Rob
a question cuz I'm not trying to put
your business out there but you've had
some issues with your Teslas let's just
say that I yeah I total okay okay and
Malik's crashed you've been some
accidents you had someu but yet you
continue to return back to tesle and you
bought another Tesla safest vehicle I've
ever owned that's why so what's the
reason it's a I would have died if I was
in any other type of car uh in the
Collision that I was in I spun out
somebody rear ended me I spun out on the
highway hit a guard rail going 75 mph
total the car walked away completely
unharmed no not concussion nothing no
uned what did I say unarmed unarmed
armed uh I was unharmed in the accident
so that's why I went back for they're
great vehicles uh economically it
doesn't cost me anything to charge this
thing up and it's a very safe vehicle
for me and my kids Goa safety thought on
this with with Herz what do you have
with this by the way great commentary
Rob Tom what are your thoughts well I i'
line up Herz head the number one problem
they had was the customers weren't
taking it so they couldn't find enough
customers to rent the EV so it started
there but then it went to all the things
that you talked about what Rob talked
about which is you know if you don't
drive an EV a lot you don't know how to
charge it and you don't know how to set
it and a lot of times these EVS were
getting run out of gas and getting
stalled someplace because people that
didn't understand it were running them
out of gas so there was a cost so there
was a bunch of cost underlying herts in
this and the fact that the uh audience
the people that were renting from here
didn't want it and The Verge likes to
say buy more gas guzzlers no they're not
they're buying a bunch of cars that are
four-cylinder engines some of them are
even hybrids and that's what they're
buying for the fleet so it's not like
they're buying a bunch of you know BMW
m5s to get 11 miles a gallon here that's
that's what's going on so The Verge you
know congratulations for spinning the
headline but oh I'm sorry I just noticed
it's The Verge um and so what Herz has
done is the Practical thing they said
hey we you got to go back to fuele
efficient cars that everybody wants to
rent so they don't get stranded and then
the other thing is is what he was
pointing out is EVs do not have an
infrastructure for repair so her is
making the right decision I have the
same thing I have a Fisker that's in my
tiny little fleet of bisoc cars and you
know I you know there's things that only
Fisker can work on if it ever comes to
that and I and I know that and that's a
a risk I take something I accept you
know by supporting that company with
their car right now and supporting up to
a point I think a blend is good but Herz
everybody's jumping on Herz here but
Herz is just doing the the normal thing
I can't get enough people to rent these
things and I got increased cost of the
ones that I have and so I'm going to so
I'm going to sell them and that's that
and by the way Herz is also suffering
because Herz has been impacted by Uber
and turo is actually mentioned in a
quarterly earnings report um I believe
it was Enterprise They mentioned turo
which you can rent a car from somebody
else a day turo is basically the um
Airbnb for cars turo is like the churos
they sell out magic M ex cousin of that
a Mexican dessert but the point is Herz
and Avis and all the car rental
companies have been hit by Uber and
turos Tom you want a herdz
donut so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right
here